I gotta leave some time for this because
this is my favorite story
of the year so far uh easily and
potentially of the century I don't know
but it's a good one so the ISU European
figure skating championships at espoo
Metro Arena
took place last week
where is espoo Metro Arena I have no
idea
somewhere in Europe we can assume and it
began with what was billed as a
spectacular opening ceremony meant to
celebrate equality and diversity that's
what it was about and for a little more
on this ceremony here's the write-up on
the espoo 2023 website it says this
the ISU European figure skating
championship at espu Metro Arena will
begin on Wednesday 25th 25th of January
with a spectacular opening ceremony
drawing its inspiration from the event's
theme which is just Bu The Finnish
figure skating Association promotes the
importance of equality and diversity and
develops skating according to its values
the theme just just bu will be visible
part of the opening ceremony with
performers from various backgrounds the
half hour opening ceremony was designed
by synchronized skating coach Helena
tynhara together with choreographer and
Coach uh with a name that I'm not going
to pronounce
quote with the diverse group of
performers we want to show that the ice
has space for everyone the opening
ceremony will present skaters at various
levels from non-professionals to top
athletes on the ice we will see single
skater synchronized skaters and pairs
including
um included among the performers are
figure skater Nina Maria
anti-kinen who defines herself as a
gender-neutral woman and then other
performers as well okay so
about this fellow and it is a fellow
first of all this is a man he is a
Finnish dude in his 60s and is
apparently always dreamed of being an
ice princess is what he has said and he
now identifies as a woman and as an ice
princess and so they put him out on the
ice for the opening ceremony of this
what I what I think is like a major
figure skating event
and um
he we'll show you what that looks like
and and uh
well first of all before we show you the
video I think we have a just a
photograph of the guy himself could we
put that up on the screen
do we have the photo of the actual ice
skater okay there he is
so looks a bit like maybe a uh
a cross-dressing Tommy Lee Jones perhaps
you know he actually looks like Stephen
King a little bit he looks like like a
creepy somehow a creepier Stephen King
if Stephen King was a character in a
Stephen King novel then that's what that
guy is
um in other words a truly beautiful
woman and if you don't think I mean look
at this
lovely lady lady right here if you don't
think that this is the most beautiful
and gorgeous and graceful
female athlete you have ever laid your
eyes on
then you are literally Hitler
that's the truth
if you do not applaud his sorry her ice
skating performance as the most
impressive athletic display of all time
you are also Hitler
which means that they're going to be a
lot of Hitlers out there after we all
watch this performance together so let's
put this up this this was Maria
's performance on the ice no not this
one that's that's next
yeah here it is go ahead
let's watch this again
and this is actually impressive because
this is the first time
apparently been ice skating in his life
as a woman or identifies as an ice
skater Falls
oh my God
on
what a performance remarkable you know
and the audience is just watching like
are we allowed to laugh at this are we
supposed to laugh at this the audience
has no idea and this is in Europe
especially they're they're very afraid
uh they don't know what they're supposed
to do
but they're really looking at each other
like is this supposed to be good what
are we supposed to do here
well you laugh at it that's what you're
supposed to do
um that's what you're meant to do
honestly I took my kids I think I
mentioned this I took my kids ice
skating a couple of weeks ago and um it
was my
maybe third time ever putting on ice
skates and the other two times were I
don't know 20 years ago on like a date
or something and I was more graceful
than that and I'm I'm not even
exaggerating I was significantly better
than that
compared to that guy I'm practically
I can't name any famous figure skaters
so I can't really finish the analogy but
whatever's the most famous one I'm
practically that person compared to that
guy but it gets better uh because this
guy also this actually is not his first
time strap it on the skates he also
competed at an event in 2020 where he
gave a performance that was uh inspired
by Japanese culture let's watch this one
[Music]
I mean this
this in every sense looks like a scene
from a Will Ferrell movie in 2003.
but it's not this is real
[Music]
you know what's strange he's actually
gotten worse in the last two years
because this is a little bit better than
what we just saw
he's regressing
uh look at that okay he's on one leg
I don't know I don't know if I could do
that I didn't try
foreign
not a joke oh it does a little uh twirly
thing
well
that's how is it how is that better that
was it was three years ago how has it
gotten worse since then
I don't know if it's the the hormones
they have them on or what
so this one is good because this is like
an appropriation hat trick he's
appropriating Womanhood appropriating
Japanese culture and appropriating
figure skating all at the same time
but this is how the appropriation math
works it actually cancels so you would
think well that's three times more
offensive than than other forms of
appropriation
um no because it actually it cancels it
all cancels each other out
and um
because he's appropriating Womanhood at
the same time as appropriating Japanese
culture it cancels out and then it
actually becomes uh not only something
that's okay and appropriate but
something that we should celebrate
and I do celebrate it and so I'd like to
see more of I want this guy in the
Olympics okay I want him winning gold as
a female figure skater in the Olympics
let's just go all the way and make
everything into a total mockery
because that's all it is and I'll do it
for this portion so as we move over to
the members block if you're not a member
yet you can become a member and use code
wall should check out for two months
free on all annual plans hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]